[Music]
welcome back to off the record where we
talk about whatever
we want and i guess we're not talking
about whatever we want we're going to
talk about crypto because
you're telling me uh come on careful hey
don't spill the beef i'm not gonna smell
the beans yet
i don't want to talk about crap though
can we talk about everything else though
okay we're not spilling the beans on the
new one though no no not the new one i'm
just saying
uh look what's going on what i don't
want to talk about cursed up oh come on
geo
you're supposed to be it's all guys day
yeah what a girl so why are girls so
allergic to crypto
are we allergic to crypto seems like it
sometimes i wonder how you got a [ __ ]
girlfriend a [ __ ] wife and a [ __ ]
kid
that are actually heavy into crypto what
do you know what cosmos is
what's that what yeah yeah yeah why
don't guys ever know that huge huge huge
huge
crypto it's not the girl magazine
i don't know how many cars are into
crypto one of the developers there is a
chip
yeah she's a fan too i know a lot of
chicks oh
oh [ __ ] talk about that no you're
getting off subject yeah what are their
names
list them all go i gotta tell you right
now this has been the highly requested
like they just can't get enough of
crypto
with us all right fine all right i'll
back up you don't want them to make
money
that's how the market is the market's
demanding it you know okay my bad i
[ __ ] up i i'll back off
everyone's talking about crypto right
now too everybody everybody even people
who shouldn't talk about crypto talk
about carp
yep yeah especially the technical
analysis kids that are on so funny this
is why
dodge coin is going to the moon so let
me get this this is why bitcoin just hit
a death cross it's not coming back it's
a bear market
[ __ ] noobs got wrecked again
go figure my my question is [ __ ]
noobs getting wrecked
i love when steve says that he's my
favorite sell
every [ __ ] bottom it's so funny how
cool you don't have a crypto channel
right do it dude i do
i do something on my nikki's patreon
called crypto corner and it's been great
i have a great little community there
but but other than that yeah it's it's
uh i'd like to keep it all there because
if i have like a little movie move i
don't want everyone to be buying in on
my move before i
get to accumulate more of it my question
is can you make a kill in
off of coinbase alone or in order to
make a kill in like
like like to do the real moves like you
have to
be on like all the other like uh what do
you call it exchanges
exchanges yeah depends on the time of
the year because right now ultra very
very juicy right
and sometimes it might be a period it
could be also your period
but that's the thing right so because
like for example if you were just
holding bitcoin this whole time right
now since january you're only up like 15
as of today because of the way the
market just cut up cut in half couple
months ago you're up like a crazy
right but that's why but alt is not the
case alts ran
much harder than bitcoin did which is
why i've been more interested in alt
this whole time but that doesn't mean
that bitcoin would be on other exchanges
though which is way more complicated
because the reason why i'm asking is
like i hate being on the other exchanges
because it seems way more sketchy
coinbase seems way more friendlier well
risk reward right but also
the there's so many coins on coinbase
now it's so much different than it was
in like 2017
2018 where there's like five or seven
you were investing that long ago i was
investing in 2013.
wow that's when he first came up he's
the god he's a godfather at this point
what the hell happened he got a theory
man like ten bucks i gotta throw him at
eight
do you have like millions of dollars no
comments
you heard it here first folks millions
no more millions more millions
but yeah no there's a lot of interesting
place right now and the market's gonna
be much
like different this time i think
everything's a cycle right but the
market's going to be different this time
because there's so much institutional
buying going on right now
that's that still means the cycle will
be intact but does that mean that we'll
see like
90 drops on a lot of this [ __ ] who knows
maybe 50. the next
the next big guy that's going to buy up
uh i'm surprised apple hasn't yet
if they're not pro if they're not otc
buying right now like over-the-counter
buying where they don't
impact the price they're like buying
like through other markets they have
something in your portfolio
they just released so like you know
public companies they have to show what
their
um assets are or they have to show like
they
like companies own like because they're
publicly traded right yeah
so they have to show what they own and
um
yeah this just came out that a lot of
them own bitcoin google apple
facebook like a lot of them they own
bitcoin yeah so that's the thing right
so as those
player big players come in and hold it
does that mean that it has the same
volatility that
that we're all accustomed to right i
mean but then the market just chopped 50
percent in half
because i think a lot of big players
came in to accumulate as well so they
touched like [ __ ] elon exactly he
came in and was like sleep
sweep sweep peace he came in created a
problem and then solved it
you gotta love it i'm surprised he's not
being investigated for like
inciting trading if the sec gave a [ __ ]
about that [ __ ] they would be
arresting people but they never do
that's the beauty they pay a fine so
what's that one exchange the one that
[ __ ]
started like a lot of people yeah [ __ ]
those guys but even those guys what what
happened they go to the senate
and then that thing happened hey bad
guys
didn't chase jp morgan just pay like a
huge fine for some kind of silver
trillion dollars
billion dollar fine for silver
manipulation yeah the silver market got
manipulated by those guys
and yeah people that's rare that's right
and that's what people don't know about
or talk about
is that these markets all get
manipulated all the time but people act
like crypto some unique thing where
everything's getting manipulated it's an
abnormal thing do you think people
really think that
unfortunately yes people watch the nbc
and all the normies [ __ ] yeah normally
[ __ ]
these terms dudes the poor normans yeah
selling every [ __ ] dump paper handing
all the way down
and then and then selling like the
lowest low and then
they can't believe the market came back
what the [ __ ] went on i watched my
favorite ta guy he said it's [ __ ]
over
like that's what's so frustrating about
all this stuff is they don't respect the
cycle
they were they're too zoomed in on this
moment and they think like
oh my god everything matters right now
because i'm over leveraged everybody who
lower over leverages [ __ ] themselves
i was just watching this thing on the
history channel about the uh
the stock market crash of 1929 was like
black tuesday
and it was exact same [ __ ] people lost
faith in the stocks because we weren't
producing as much and then the investors
were
over confident so that's when it started
tanking and as soon as it starts tanking
who comes and who yeah everyone runs and
it's it's
a domino effect that gets triggered but
who comes in and sweeps and buys
everything
pennies on the dollar all the ballers
all the ballers are waiting for this
moment
they come and buy up everything and
everyone two or three x's they're
stacked
of course the cycle flips in about a
decade at the time
and then when the economy comes back up
all those people that came in and
swooped in were
balling the [ __ ] out i mean there's
fundamentals right yeah it's the same
cycle because
it's psychological more than anything
like people sell because they don't have
faith and then they buy because they
think that it's gonna be
make them rich yeah and the actual jp
morgan the guy was still alive at the
time
he came out and he was like hey everyone
i think the market's stable and then
before did the big crash it went like
this and it pumped up almost like what
elon did
with bitcoin and doge and then uh
afterwards like
a celebrity coming out and talking can
only sustain the market so much so it
did crash hella hard but then he came in
he just bought up
did you know that elon has bitcoin nodes
that they're running
like like elon has been running bitcoin
nodes which is a huge power drain
according to what elon's saying
like but tesla was doing that tesla he
even came out in a tweet
when he said hey guess what tesla is
going to be
um accepting bitcoin payments and we're
not going to be selling it
we have bitcoin notes he said that well
if you plug in your tesla
to the wall where does that power come
from
mostly coal especially in the united
states it comes mostly from coal so the
idea that somehow he has this electric
car that you can plug into the wall and
that's less environmentally
concerning than bitcoin which you also
plug into the same [ __ ] outlet
like the idea of it is so stupid but
what people don't understand is that
tesla is subsidized heavily by carbon
credits and by environmental credits
seven percent government seven percent
of their profits came
from government subsidies this past year
so he has a financial incentive
literally
to to try to keep that money train going
and that's why he's flooding the market
about bitcoin especially because one of
his biggest investors
is heavily talking about environmental
[ __ ] they're called arc
investing right and they're they're one
of the biggest
like firms out there and they are big on
you know environmental concerns with
bitcoin all this stuff so
he's heavily like they have one of the
biggest holdings of tesla shares you
think that all these things are
independent like of course not there's
market manipulation going on and either
you can see see it going on and
recognize it or you can call me a
conspiracy theorist and
and then just hold your nose and good
luck well i think it just depends on who
you're
talking to because if you're talking to
amateurs yeah they're all gonna
act this way like and and the the
earliest of retail investors
right but if you're talking to like
hedge guys or you're talking about guys
like
you know they're in it like this is
their day-to-day
t-shirt wears
you're talking about like crypto guys
that's been around
or maybe if they stuck around since 2017
right
like they they're not going to be so
scared like i think that's the crash of
2017 we just had a bunch of
um let's face it like nerds that aren't
business people
like most of them it was either
engineers that were part of the project
that had
crypto because they you know that's how
they got paid or like
incentivized or they were like you know
computer forward guys with money with a
little bit of money
and so yeah it's easy to scare them but
it's not easy to scare
institutional guys exactly and when the
institutional guys are
you know they basically help um
raise all this awareness in the media of
like oh my god bitcoin is
it's really bad investment right now you
should get out like all that stuff
is coordinated you can literally see
them using the same buzz words in every
article do you ever think about holding
other countries currency how do you mean
i do you like euros or like oh you do i
have korean juan
how come you have that but you think
it's the next [ __ ] no i i got
tim you always talk with your eyes look
at him it's always eyebrow and eyes
eyebrows dude there's no facial
expression but this it's like he's
trying to have sex with everybody hey
what do you think
what i'm waiting for is china to issue
their first
um cbdc or central bank central bank
digital digital currency
where they're basically taking the yen
and putting it on the blockchain
and they just recently talked about
putting um putting on the ethereum
blockchain which would be
super bullish for ethereum so there's a
lot going on right now that
is going to change the world that we
know the us will probably be the last to
do it too because they have this
a nice little scam going mm-hmm all i
know is i'm gonna ride
steve's coattails all i know is i'm dumb
as [ __ ] all i know is if i made
millions like millions my chair would
look like this
that's it just millions this is what jk
news would look like
great welcome
[Laughter]
if that's the case check out sheep dude
go all in on sheep
shiva bro i got shiva eating only
because i like doing the show so i want
you to be around
[Laughter]
i was like wait i'm gonna buy some right
now yo that [ __ ] pumped right after doge
sure did my friend got it super early
too the meme coins
just have had an insane run right now
it's just funny
this is so funny i like the way that
dogecoin was clowning on our financial
system
and then now a bunch of institutional
players that's all it takes is a couple
to support it and then everyone goes
holy [ __ ] this might be a good idea
and then there's the baseball the
baseball team that's going to take it
exactly
i thought there's a couple of stadiums
that's going to take doge um the
mavericks are already
accepting doge for merch that's so cool
you could pay with doge yeah dang it
might be a good thing
is that dog getting any cuts no dogs
just using it's like
like they should have had an nfc then i
know
come on so much that meme like it was
like some
japanese like what do you call it like a
dog channel or instagram
was it yeah i think it was like some
famous dog yeah
and now they can't use it anymore and
they or they get a cut i don't know but
i want a problem
there's no satoshi nakamoto necessarily
for doge in the same way
because it's not as mysterious the guy
already came out and said he's broke or
whatever
wait didn't he sell doge yeah he sold
doge way earlier he was like this is
[ __ ] there was it was a joke for him and
then he just [ __ ]
sold all of his dough he has no doge he
like sold oh my god he hates his life i
think he still made a decent come up but
like not
one of them sold the one of the creators
sold it so that he could buy a honda
civic
wow yeah and then he could have bought
[ __ ] a whole car game bought the
whole honda
but yeah you saw that i mean i don't
think if i was an engineer for that [ __ ]
like i wouldn't
i'd be doing it for shits and giggles
not thinking like one day
you know it's going to be billions of
[ __ ] dollars because that was the
pretense of how they made that coin
right it was just
it's a it's a [ __ ] meme coin yeah genius
it's so smart because because our
financial system is the same [ __ ] in
fact
did you guys see that meme where it's
like unlimited supply like it goes down
by
certain percent every year all this [ __ ]
and then they go oh yeah that's we're
talking about the us dollar
i thought if steve immediately i was
like dude steve is right steve is right
there's actually people who think money
is real though like money isn't real
is that what you said no that money is
real oh i thought you were yeah oh no
no it's yeah there's people that believe
that it's like real
right you're like well of course it's
real look i can see it i can touch it i
can feel it i can use it to buy things
and um yeah i was listening to this uh
old
philosopher dude named alan watts and he
had a whole thing about
money and he was talking to a bunch of
economists and a bunch of guys and
and he was like saying you know this is
just a construct right and then we just
agreed
that it has value and then we have an
exchange and all that and
and then they're laughing at them and
i'm all like wait that's so easy to just
get like anything
can be absolutely if we all agree that
this kirkland water bottle
is worth a hundred thousand dollars
right and if a million people
agree that this is what it's
worth then it becomes that that's all it
doesn't even take that many because look
at chicken nuggets
among us if you're willing to pay for it
yeah
that's it that's what things are worth
it's what people are willing to pay for
what were the economists saying that
they didn't like that they didn't
believe or was uh i don't remember but
it was just that they thought he was
preposterous like basically it's like of
course it's real i can use it i can see
it you can use it
like it's it's it's there it's like wait
wait you're we talking about in the 60s
oh because back in the day was actually
backed by something
so then for them they were backed by
gold but even gold the contract of gold
is that we all agree that this shiny
beautiful thing is worth a lot
yeah for sure but i'm just saying like
that thought
when that's not explained it sounds
super far-fetched and like they're just
[ __ ] nuts
right but it was universally valuable
like gold right like so when when
nixon nixed the gold standard in the
early 70s that's when
like you're saying like it all was
backed by nothing exactly
yeah but people don't even know that so
like that's what's frustrating is that
you can just print more
like what what's biden doing right now
like a six trillion dollar oh my god
it's just gonna be just printed again
and that and what that means by the way
for people at home watching this is just
that everything that you're gonna buy
goes up just like under trump they did
the same [ __ ] thing
under obama this i understand how people
don't know that well
that's what they're like raise their
[ __ ] minimum wage but it's like do
you understand like the chained reaction
that happens
they're not taught in schools like what
these things do or what
printing more money actually does the
impact it has on poor people
even they don't even know that it's a
poor people tax people with assets guess
what they did
during this entire covid crisis they
raised the price of everything that they
own because they hold
massive amounts of assets everything
that they have went up like
multiples while cash got super super
super cheap
and people don't have as much faith in
it and so now you guess what
you go out to dinner you go to the
movies or whatever it's going to get
more expensive i mean we see it on gas
prices like
it happened overnight dude everything's
like a dollar extra for galileo well
hollywood six dollars
for guests who pays who pays
it's the poor the poor people are paying
the biggest tax on all this stuff
and that and while we forgive all this
other [ __ ] and when we pay for jeff
it's the middle class actually well
we'll them too cause i feel like the
poor are getting some sort of
i mean we have to define what the poor
is right but like i'm assuming the poor
they're getting like government
supplies and [ __ ] but like i feel like
the middle class are the ones getting
double [ __ ]
well the government supplies thing right
like when you look at what they actually
get
it it it's like like section section 8
housing for example
like it sucks yeah like it all sucks the
system like that
but who's paying for that right that the
rich
kind of aren't i think it's the middle
class right because the rich know how to
move their money
that's exactly right but the real rich
not yet that's all it is right not like
a guy not like your neighbor with a bmw
that's not good
not like your local doctor with a couple
hundred thousand dollars
salary for the real reason they're real
rich the guys who are making like
multiple multiple baltimore millions
like
when people think rich they think oh
this person with a couple million
that they make every year that's that's
like upper middle class jeff bezos's
space program idea for eight billion
dollars is about to get written off by
the government
that's what i'm talking about when i say
the rich right like there's a game being
played on all of us that
people don't see necessarily because
they just go oh well you know
they don't even look at that and the way
that the washington post writes about it
is not going to be the same as everybody
else because he owns them
so like that's that's what i mean but
you can use the media if you're rich
enough to manipulate everyone to just
think that you're the greatest
and it scares me yeah but i also don't
blame the people that want 15 bucks an
hour to because it's like they don't
know
they just want to feed their family so
they're like yo okay
simple math i can't pay my bills if i
only have 15 bucks
instead of like 10 bucks an hour i can
[ __ ] do it but they don't know that
voting that in is actually hurting them
because then they might get cut from the
job
completely well they also don't well
there's a whole other side of that too
because we're talking about inflation
right now so guess what the cost of
things are about to go up
so do people need maybe more of a
minimum wage absolute [ __ ] lutely
because they are
money they're creating the problem and
then they're offering no solution ever
and then and then they create this rich
versus poor thing where they go
hey small business owners got to worry
about a minimum wage thing but they're
the ones
inflating everything making it this nuts
yep yeah so
it's a catch-22 all the way up but
inflation is great for bitcoin
it's great for crypto you know what's
bad for crypto
is a stable banking system that is
actually
doing what they're supposed to do yeah
and making your money work for you yeah
yeah that'll never happen like 0.5
percent
yeah because if the if the banking
system worked we wouldn't have crypto
like there would be no point for crypto
i need for an alternative nope
what would be um a banking system that
does work
like how is it supposed to work right
because the way i know it is they get
your money
they pay you a percentage and then they
reinvest your money and they get a
higher percentage
but what is it they pay you um half a
percentage maybe that's the key
they're making a lot of money off of
your money but there's nobody there
saying wait a minute you're making this
much money off of their money how come
they're not getting this percent of that
that's the key that's missing in the mix
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you